preso tutti ragazzi benvenuti avessero
video sono fa vigenti san suu kyi che
parta faccia per dirlo perché
impossibile
praticamente un videogame tipo sporche
sarebbe questo sono io c'è il gran figo
che sono stata cosa c'è una zolletta di
zucchero in testa cos'è sta roba ragazzi
è un mio dio
ciao tu sei un mago un cane quanto è
passato ragazzi come 20 secondi di gioco
ed è perché già non sto capendo più
incazzoso picchiare le linee gli animali
no no no no no sto scherzando scherzando
sotto schiaffo o mio dio sono aggredito
da un pavon cane e mi fate capire cosa
posso lanciare le ciliegie cazzo è una
bomba
forchia troyer bene ricominciamo se io
posso creare gli animali credo a quanto
ho visto grande allora è posso costruire
il mio mostro fantastico quindi io posso
certo non è carino una palla e mischiate
il pallone anche questo dovrebbe sapere
se lo puoi mettere sulle it
no questo non serve anche cosa ho fatto
se ci riprova un miliardo di volte non
ci riesco a chi è oggi a questo super
sayan ragazzi ma ci sono anche le zampe
sono fantastico perfetto ragazzi ha
creato questa roba
credo sia una mucca con tre occhi
contesta di pavone gambe di giraffa
allora sono uscito o mio dio
la creatura adesso è viva ma giove cos'è
no salve mi scusi eh
ciao porcava quanto sei brutto posso
adottarlo ragazzina seriamente se un
figo io ti ho creato io ti distruggo
caione ep rossi 6 giocare a calcio ti va
di fare la partita si chiamerà giselda
ciao giselda come stai o amore del babbo
carina e non si pensa al babbo è non si
pensa al bar
ecco la porta wing sayat ecco perche
portiamo al guinzaglio vieni qua dove
cazzo pensi tu segui il papa e fai quel
che cazzo vogliono
hai presente le barbie che ti ho
comprato dal televoto male che c'è il
guinzaglio attaccato all'occhio province
tra tutti i posti in cui potrà mettere
costati onde gli schiaffi tar cosa hai
capito di quello che ho detto [__] è
[Applauso]
stata mia figlia a mie ragazze
[Musica]
il rotto collane maggio almeno tu
l'hamburger non mica niente nessuno se
li caga tamburiate accordo ragazzi
proviamo un qualcosa di un po di verve
lino senso fare una roba provo a farlo
serio a vedere stesso inserisca fare un
serpente serio senza mixare e fare tipo
roba che manco frankenstein o che ha
scelto la creatura più semplice della
terra tra tutte come potevo scegliere
eccolo qua mamma mia che figo gli occhi
grazie ragazzi o no ma no ma no dai non
fatto storto ragazzine anche il
basilisco di harry potter era così
brutto ragazzi ci siamo lo fa come che
posso da parte che un po spezzato sto
serpentara lo è perché un giurarci vuole
questa perché se non c'è questa manca
tutto fermi che voi che può dirlo è un
serpente unico unicorn serpente rica e
il serpente più statico che abbia mai
visto e fermo io
ciao senti ciao ciao sono famiglie che
ho creato io quindi ho creato io quindi
p comando io
raiola non si gioca coi pezzi del suo
corpo però sempre detto piano piano no
si spazi bravo brave di che cos'è mag il
mio piccolo come capiente sei fermo e
non fa incassato allora piccolo mio cosa
cosa facciamo vedi che ti vedo annoiato
no no no no no no no no ti tolgo la
playstation se fai cazzati si tolgono a
play è uscito qualcosa di una troika non
sono io sua madre a the plaza
ho fatto io t'ho fatti conosco io vieni
col babbo la mcdonald's che andiamo già
vieni perfetto bravo segui la scia degli
hamburger è una roba mangia anche questo
è se lo trovi buono non lo so troppo
piccante ma questo è uomo di creatura
così se lo lancia in scena che cosa
cazzo succede un mio tiro ciao sono dopo
dj piacere sono spesso i cani di prima
bello del siggraph sai che lo sapete che
faccio un altro qualcos'altro
come dire questa è la cosa più brutta
che abbia mai l'istituto la mia vita
scusa st of m a ragazzi e parte che
questi sono i gemelli sono usciti uguali
termiche mi ammazzate cane termini
oddio sostanze ragazzi si stanno
stuprando il cane non è un problema
verso prodotti che si riesca a fare
qualcosa che assomiglia a un milione e
dopo ben quattro ore di lavoro il minion
perfetto signore e signori ecco a voi
ragazzi vi presento josef
si chiama ciao saluta farti vedere non
fare il team no dai non fare il timido
come solito da ieri da papà vieni no
della lega senza cena il rapporto che
c'è tra mesto mio figlio ecco è quello
che c'è tra me e mia madre la mattina a
bello ci capiamo
o mio dio fermati e piano piano piano le
gare che cazzo scegliere yabasta fermati
comunque ragazzi secondo me si fanno
male questa scoccola cosa attaccata all
occhio ragazzi firmiamo una petizione
non se ne può più di vedere maltrattati
così le creature non tick a non prestare
se cosa ti ha fatto che il cazzo di
sacchetto calmati ove prendi st palla
posso creare delle altre cose perché i
ragazzi le uova sono ci servono troppo
perché sempre una donna che fantasia se
vuole ci siamo ragazzi sono usciti a
capo dio non vi accoppiate mentre no ho
detto non vi è accoppiato santo dio
ragazzi stiamo assistendo è sto facendo
il video bravo non gli hanno usare fuga
non di annunciare il culo per l'amor di
dio
la donna è durato un cazzo speedy
gonzales chiuso a cazzo creato tra
l'altro no no pensava di poter creare un
cactus
però mi son belle casa fai è fatto di
zollette di zucchero suono che ho messo
degli occhi ovunque ragazzi prova a fare
un abominio ci provo non lo so se riesco
più perfette ragazzi allora abbiamo i
nostri cari che si ingrossano molti anni
dopo a quello che vorrebbero l'on
il cane che è andato a giocare nel parco
e poi abbiamo lui no no no non mi
schiaccia fermo sono uscito sono uscito
farmi tutti sono fuori stai lì noto
azzardare uscire ora sei mio figlio è
roba tipo cosa è che se c'è tra l'altro
di fa finisce tutto finisce il mondo ci
vuole il test dell'hamburger per capire
quanto è profondo ragazze o ragazzi la
scoperta eccovi in venuto anch'io ho già
che ci sono bellissimo comunque ho
creato miei figlioli stata la cosa più
bella del mondo non allora io so che c'è
un gioco similissimo che si chiama spore
ho perso latenza e subito voluto
provarlo quindi ragazzi perdonatemi solo
trovare un episodio
basta cadere perdonatemi se voluto
provarci ma è con queste creature qui
con le pezze al culo come faccio a non
lo sono fantasmi allo ragazzi concludo
che l'episodio spero che vi sia piaciuto
è piaciuto anche a lui un mi piace per
lui perché poverino ecco è morto
probabilmente il sito ci sono anche su
youporn e poi non vado a controllare
cosa sento seguito è piaciuta per come
mi piace anche al pagina di facebook e
condividerla tale descrizione cesar si
discute ci vediamo al provino per
ragazzi